everybody excited for the carnival sure
I am
Pass
you're still going what time do I need
to be there set up noon spot
well you're helping out yeah why I want
to support mom man God you're just doing
it cuz Veronica's gonna be there
and who made Veronica hmm
mom what you're coming with us right no
I'm not come on it'll be fun
the old lady wants to be cranky and
alone you got to respect that I am NOT
cranky and I'm sick of everybody
thinking that they know what's best for
me hey did everybody see there's a sale
at Radio Shack on nine volt batteries
it's a golden opportunity to stock up
[Music]
yeah hey we're getting ready to head
over to the carnival good for you
why don't you come with us because I'm
quite content right where I am
don't you think it'll be nice to get out
of the house I can't believe I didn't
think of that thank you
so you're coming no still cranky again
what have you been on the couch all day
no for your information I got up put my
slippers on cross the street broke into
your house and stole your beer oh listen
if you've just come over here to badger
me please don't fun I brought you fried
chicken from the carnival I don't need
your pity chicken look I know you're
having a tough time I'm fine okay does
that mean you'll still take Sheldon to
dr. sturgess's class yeah but I'm fine
so you won't mind if I take him do
whatever you want
see when you say it like that it sounds
like you might mind how about this
darling daughter please do it ever it is
that makes you happy if you're gonna act
like this and I'm gonna leave oh no
after I didn't open the door for you hey
wait give me a beer oh well let's get me
some chicken got your beer they give me
any problem no change you keep it
hey I may be too drunk to drive but I
still can count to six Mary I don't
think I've ever seen you here before
it's my first time huh I took her on a
tour she's extremely thorough so uh
how's Connie actually Sheldon why don't
you go save me a seat smart the front
row is a hot ticket anyway uh mom's good
because she's usually the one who brings
children well she's been pretty busy
lately
relationships are a waste of time do you
think Tarzan was happy with Jane
no he was happy swinging through the
trees Liberty she's got her book and her
torch and she's good uh-huh I'm glad
she's doing well tell her I say hi
I will do that actually no tell her I
said hello a bit casual or wait
greetings just say greetings from John
you don't sound sure about that no I
don't the best thing is for you to just
forget about this Veronica girl you
should be playing the field just like a
bumblebee going from flower to flower
and don't get confused about all this
love nonsense your freedom is the only
thing that matters
mmm be a sweet boy and get me motel
any coffee you need a shower
[Music]
Missy five minutes oh can you please
sorry been there she's hungover wants us
to keep it down
[Music]